if I could return actually to the
question of Beauty for a second I forgot
to ask you something you mentioned
imperfection in the Death Masks mhm what
role does
imperfection play in um our conception
of beauty what role does imperfection
play in um in nature there's uh there's
this Japanese Aesthetics concept of wabu
saabi which BAS basically uh Embraces
imperfection nothing lasts nothing is
finished and nothing is perfect what
what do you think of that I totally
agree that change is the only permanence
that imperfection is there if only to to
signal that we are part of a bigger
thing than ourselves that that we are on
a journey um that that
we're that things are in
movement um and if they were perfect I
of of course when things are perfect it
is just so boring we end up with
stereotypes and as humans but I think
just in general as living beings we're
here to find meaning and that meaning
cannot be F found without struggle and
without seeking to not to perfect but to
build toward to build toward something
better um when I was a child my mother
who who who I love so much always
explain to me how important it is to
fall and to fail and to fight and to
argue and
um and that there is a way that there's
a culture to to to to failing and and
and to
imperfection um so I I think it is it is
uh necessary for something beautiful to
be imperfect and it is a sign that it it
is a sign of nature because nothing in
nature is perfect
effect